I'm overwhelmed overwhelmed with joy and
happiness and Delight for the women in
this country this is not about the money
this is about getting my name back and
that's what we accomplished Robbie had
to tell me later how much the damage is
worth
here is the astonishing thing about this
win yesterday
of all the cases that this man faces all
the legal quagmires
it was one what was sick of all the
prosecutors all the special counsel all
the investigators and what happened
yesterday is one five foot two little
blonde Wiley female attorney and one 79
year old
yes five foot nine five five foot nine
79 year old advice columnists
beat Donald Trump in court
it is a moment which before yesterday
uh there was a concept of the perfect
victim perfect the perfect victim always
screams always reports to the police
always makes note when it happened and
then her life is supposed the perfect
victim's life is supposed to fold up and
she's never sort of supposed to be happy
again and yesterday we demolished that
old concept it is gone it is gone and
I'm I'm overwhelmed with happiness for
the women of the country it's really not
about me so much it's about every woman
I said it to Joe takapina yesterday
he came over to congratulate I mean he
put out his hand and I said
he did it and you know it
and then we shook hands and I passed by
so I got my chance to say it